hi my name is Yu Feng Guo and today
we're going to explore how you can build
a solution with Google Cloud AI by
taking a look at the use case of using
AI and manufacturing for increased
productivity our example comes from the
machining industry so let's first talk a
bit about what machining is machining is
the process for cutting raw materials
such as metal wood or plastic into a
desired final shape in size modern
machine shops use computer-controlled
precision machining tools for operations
like cutting drilling boring milling and
so on machining is an essential part of
the manufacturing industry historically
a major challenge of the machining
industry is the time-consuming task of
cost estimation for instance when a
machine shop takes an order for building
parts like these it needs to determine
the individual cuts and holes that need
to be made for each individual part by
carefully reading the blueprint provided
by the customer
this manual process requires machining
experts who are dedicated to the cost
estimation process which can act as a
bottleneck for the productivity of the
machine shop as a whole a company called
kibou qu in Japan has launched a new
solution for this challenge by handling
the data management of their machining
process with AI kibou qu is a start-up
focused on modernizing the manufacturing
industry with 3d printing cloud and AI
technologies for major manufacturing
customers including Toyota Honda and
Olympus let's see how Kabu cooze data
management tool works first a blueprint
is uploaded to the tool in the web
browser and a region is specified for
estimation then the user simply presses
the cost estimation button the tool
detects and highlights every object that
requires processing you can see the
detected types of processing steps how
many there are how much each costs and
the total estimated cost for the entire
part the tool also allows users to add
detailed info for each part or to have
experts update any part that requires
minor fixes the tool can detect tens of
processing parts on the design in less
than one second which significantly
increases the productivity of cost
estimation by machining experts
Masahiko Adashi CEO of kabuki explains
the benefit of this tool if machine
shops can respond quickly to cost
estimation requests from their customers
that's a better customer experience and
more business opportunities additionally
this tool can act as a central
repository of expert knowledge for each
machine shop this allows the shop to
easily share knowledge with junior staff
members and learners without any
bottlenecks and make business operations
much more scalable let's learn more
about how kabuki built this tool with
the power of Google Cloud AI kabuki tool
was able to detect the machining
operations from the blueprint to achieve
this they used our auto amel vision
technology with object detection first
they collected thousands of images in
preparation for ML model training with
different labelled blueprints for
drilling boring and cutting operations
on them usually it would take a lot of
time to build an object detection system
using their training data for production
use you would need to start with data
pre-processing ml model design hyper
parameter tuning evaluation and
deployment and would also need to have
resources to keep the model up-to-date
and that would require hiring a experts
and ml engineers for faster
time-to-market Kabukicho zaur Auto ml
technology which automates many steps in
the ML lifecycle all they had to do was
upload their training images to Auto ml
vision and press the train button to
start the automated model training and
development process
[Music]
in half a day they got an object
detection model generated by auto mail
vision with a detailed report for the
model accuracy and various metrics then
kabuki downloaded the ML model and used
it with tensorflow J s which allows you
to run the object detection within a web
browser that's the reason why Kabu cooze
machining data management tool is able
to detect tens of processing parts in
just one second even though you could
build the object detection model much
faster with Auto ml vision that's not
the whole story
one important requirement for a kabuki
tool is the ability to keep learning
from the experts the practices and
patterns used in blueprints are
different for each customer project or
machining expert so the tool provides a
UI for fixing the missed detected parts
or adding more details based on this
feedback from experts the tool reruns
the ML training process and deploys a
better ml model that captures the
practices and patterns use in each case
[Music]
to implement this continuous ml training
process kibou KU used cloud a AI
platform pipelines this product allows
users to build orchestrated ml pipelines
and manage them from data pre-processing
and validation all the way through to
model training validation and deployment
instead of asking AI experts again and
again for a manual rerun of the whole
training process everything can be
automated and continuously integrated
just by invoking the pipeline making the
whole service robust and production
ready with a high platform pipelines
seppuku was able to build a positive
feedback loop between the machining
experts and model training pipeline
resulting in ever better accuracy of
their model and higher productivity as
the experts keep using the tool this
loop of application and training is
called active learning in ml in summary
kabuki was able to use the power of
Google Cloud AI for faster
time-to-market quick abject detection
and create a flexible ml pipeline for
active learning what will your AI
journey look like get started today with
these tools from Google Cloud AI
you
[Music]